des cartes audio des écouteurs des
jeunes branchés en continu ces images
pourraient avoir été prises n'importe où
dans le monde j'écoutais beaucoup de
musique
beaucoup de musique est fort
le matin ou quand je reviens décolle que
je les coupe pas
elle n'est pas sans risque vous savez
que ça peut vous causer des problèmes à
long terme
comme ça faut assumer les conséquences
et ces conséquences selon l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé pourrait être
sévère l'analyse des pratiques d'écoute
de 19000 jeunes d'une quinzaine de pays
démontre que le quart des jeunes dans le
monde s'exposent quotidiennement des
niveaux sonores dangereux pour leur
système auditif ce qui représente autour
d'un milliard d'individus à risque l'OMS
calcule qu'en 2050 il va avoir 10% des
adultes au niveau mondial qui vont avoir
une perte significative d'audition les
audiologistes voient régulièrement des
jeunes parfois des adolescents qui ont
des pertes auditives ou souffrent
d'hypersensibilité ou bruit causée par
leurs habitudes d'écoute musicale faut
comprendre que ces pertes-là sont
cumulatives sont à long terme donc c'est
sûr que on va pas nécessairement les
détecter à un jeune âge mais on sait que
les niveaux d'exposition très élevés
vont à un moment donné produire des
pertes réversibles au Canada le seuil de
risque pour l'oreille est établi à 85
décibels pour une durée maximale de 8
heures par jour dès qu'on franchit ce
seuil il faudrait réduire son temps
d'exposition et lorsqu'on atteint des
sommets des Sybelles comme le permettent
les portables de dernière génération il
faut vraiment y aller au compte-goutte
mais la musique forte dise les experts
c'était du Léton audio on vend de plus
en plus de convertisseur audio numérique
des petits appareils qu'on installe
entre l'écouteur et le téléphone pour
augmenter la qualité et le volume de
musique donc c'est un amplificateur
littéralement
alors ça ça va faire que l'écouteur va
jouer plus fort est-ce que c'est
populaire par contre de plus en plus de
clients choisissent maintenant les
casques d'écoute qui réduisent les sons
extérieurs ce qui évite d'avoir augmenté
le volume pour les couvrir c'est sûr que
quelqu'un qui veut protéger ses oreilles
plus va avoir tendance d'aller avec un
casque
qui couvre l'oreille plus que quelque
chose intra-auriculaire mais dans les
faits dit-il il n'y a pas de recette
magique lorsque vous me dites c'est à
moi d'acheter des écouteurs pour enfants
tous les autres écouteurs se valent plus
ou moins ils peuvent pas nous protéger
les oreilles selon l'OMS il serait temps
d'agir pour contrer ce phénomène devenu
maintenant mondial une des conclusions
de l'étude c'est qu'il faut vraiment
augmenter la sensibilisation et les
normes et les
alerter les fabricants aussi de faire
baisser les niveaux de sang parce que
ces niveaux de sang là sont dangereux
pour l'audition et peuvent entraîner des
dommages permanents
Radio-Canada Montréal